in December 2016 a remote community in
Siberia experienced a mysterious
outbreak 90 people were hospitalized and
a 12 year old boy died soon Russian
officials identified what had killed him
the deadly infectious disease anthrax
the outbreak had started among reindeer
to contain the spread they burned over
2,000 reindeer carcasses the strange
thing was there hadn't been an anthrax
outbreak in the area for more than 70
years so to figure out where it came
from scientists started looking
underground in the coldest parts of the
world there's a layer of the earth that
stays frozen all year every summer the
soil above it thaws
but this deeper layer stays hard as rock
this is permafrost most permafrost is
here in the northern hemisphere around
the Arctic and because it never thaws
permafrost acts kind of like the freezer
in your kitchen when plants and animals
here die they don't actually decompose
instead they become preserved in the
frozen earth like a time capsule and
it's been that way for thousands of
years but that's changing
[Music]
today humans are burning carbon and
making the atmosphere warmer and that's
causing the permafrost to thaw and
shrink by 2100 only these areas will
still have any permafrost and that's
causing some problems when permafrost
melts the land above it becomes unstable
which can lead to landslides man-made
structures start to fall apart as the
ground underneath them collapses and
dead plants and animals that had been
frozen for years are starting to thaw
out as they're exposed to air and
bacteria this organic material starts to
decompose that releases greenhouse gases
like carbon dioxide and methane but
that's not all it releases in Siberia
scientists think that the anthrax
outbreak came from a long dead reindeer
carcass that thought out along with the
permafrost anthrax spores from the
carcass would have spread across the
area and infected reindeer grazing
nearby and it's not just anthrax
scientists worry that as permafrost
melts it could unearth all sorts of
diseases we thought we had under control
[Music]
35 million people live around permafrost
but the carbon released as permafrost
melts will accelerate the impacts of
climate change everywhere rising seas
heat waves droughts in some places and
floods and others and now we can add one
more thing to that list diseases we
thought we conquered
you
[Music]